I have a voicemail to play for you today
the voicemail number is two one nine to
david p it's actually two voicemails uh
i believe that i received a voicemail
from someone who is genuinely genuinely
suffering from significant mental
illness although maybe this is a troll I
don't think so this seems genuine to me
there are people out there who have been
bamboozled in this way by religion take
a listen hello there mr. Paquin my name
is Stephanie Korean calling from Utah
age 49 and i discovered your YouTube
channel and I just wanted to say one
thing you may not like what I have to
say but I wanted to warn you about
something go over to youtube site called
still small voice it was started by an
older lady very credible named Claire
Dubois and basically she claims she's
been talking to Jesus for quite some
time and the Jesus has instructed her
tube and I just wanted to say that that
basically a lot of people including
myself claim that we have experienced
miraculous events while over there and
you know everyone has different
experiences but I received more than
several miraculous text from Jesus with
him and notice that Jesus is a supporter
of Donald Trump and and he admits he has
flaws but he still was Jesus's choice
and called him he called him the best of
the worst candidate and said that he
still supports him to fight his flaws
and you know those are in two of the
titles actually were the titles
literally state that and then listen you
know go to those entries and listen to
what Jesus has to say and then also
after the election Jesus talks about
many things about Donald Trump including
the fact that if people do not support
him they will be punished so that's what
I'm calling to let you know about that
you could be putting yourself into grave
danger by not supporting Donald Trump
and by doing what you're doing yeah and
I know that Jesus sums for sometimes
just punish these people I actually
think it's more of them you know I look
at more of them punishing the
selves by their choices kind of like
when people are thrown into hell for
their evil choices they do it to
themselves yes you know but I do believe
it happens in fact I've witnessed
several occasions where Jesus does this
in fact he left me a text where he told
me anybody who harmed or hurts his
vessel or defame them will be punished
and um you know I actually witnessed
several people and let's stop this one
here being our guest is almost over yes
this is someone who left such a long
voicemail about this nonsense that it
timed out and then she had to call back
to continue leaving the voicemail this
is just to acccess happens every day we
get hundreds of things like this every
day but just to give you a sense of the
type of thing we're dealing with it
continued in another voicemail on to
part two anyway David if you need proof
of this you can actually contact me I
can actually even demonstrate for you
some evidence of people getting punished
and I'm actually be one of his vessels
and you know cuz I had various things
happen to me in my life since I was
seven years old and you know and these
miraculous text text that I received
from Jesus of him are just the latest
events you know miraculous things that
have happened to me but anyway if you
ever want to contact me my numbers I'd
be certainly happy to get involved to
the debate with you on your show event
and run your life program thank you yeah
uh sad very very sad presented without
comment further but we have a great
bonus show for you today out of time
can't even tell you what's on it but
it's great david pakman.com slash
membership and i voted 17 gets you a
forty percent discount off of membership
will speak to you then